il nous faudrait que stéphane rozès
politologue président de conseils
analyses et perspectives cap et rené
chiche historien professeur de
philosophie bonsoir messieurs et merci
d'être avec nous ce soir sur rtl france
à l'extension du pass and i ter a été
présentée par emmanuel macron lui même
comme le moyen de pousser à la
vaccination sont la rendre obligatoire
pour tous les français quel regard
portent les philosophes que vous êtes
sur cette démarche relais chiche
moi je considère que d'abord c'est une
faute politique majeure de la part du
président de la république dont un des
premiers de oued d'assurer la la
cohésion de la nation
cette annonce a eu
premièrement pour effet de dresser une
partie des citoyens contre les autres et
avec une violence notamment du non
verbal absolument insupportable il est
certain que les gens qui manifestent
aujourd'hui sont très en colère qu'ils
peuvent avoir des facilités verbal j'ai
entendu par les dictatures syndicats je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec ça
évidemment mais c'est une colère qui se
comprend quand on est désigné comme de
mauvais citoyens et quand on est en plus
soumis à une sorte de chantage
absolument odieux c'est pas du tout de
ce ne sont pas du tout des méthodes de
gouvernement républicain le gouvernement
républicain s'adresse à la raison à
l'intelligence et au jugement éclairé du
citoyen pas à la peur à la convoitise à
un fait on est en train finalement de
produire des comportements qui sont fort
seulement indigne de ce régime
donc voilà d'abord ce que j'ai à dire et
ça je crois que c'est la critique
fondamentale la critique la plus
importante parce que au nom d'une
situation exceptionnelle qui par
ailleurs n'est pas si inquiétante que
c'est la réalité
on est en train effectivement comme l'a
dit d'ailleurs bellamy dans son texte de
changer complètement le modèle de régime
de régime politique même si on n'en
conserve que pour la forme les
principaux éléments et était surtout de
type de société une société où des
données qui jusqu'à présent relever de
la vie prises et deviennent des
instruments de contrôle des instruments
de de pouvoir est évidemment réponses
pour que sont inquiétés c'est tout à
fait légitime de s'inquiéter donc
d'abord faute politique et puis ensuite
si maintenant je dirais quelques mots de
l'avant projet de loi qui lui est un
tissu de l'absurdité de chine va réagir
stéphane rozès est ce que vous partagez
ce point de vue est ce que c'est là une
faute politique majeure rené schérer
vaquin un chantage je m'exprime comme
politologue je suis pas un intellectuel
philosophe c'est à dire que ce qui
m'intéresse c'est effectivement de
devoir la portée politique de cette
décision et un chat d'essayer de
comprendre au fond dans une démocratie
comment fonctionne la question du
consentement le sait une société une
communauté humaine c'est un arbitrage
entre les libertés collectives des
libertés individuelles depuis en face à
des menaces plus ou moins sévères
d'autres types d'impératifs qui émerge
comme celui de la sécurité sanitaire ce
qui m'intéresse des chats comme
politologue c'est d'essayer de
comprendre pourquoi il ya un
consentement majoritaire alors s'était
dit bien éléments de peur il ya un
élément d'arbitrage entre au fond le
confinement
la vaccination est ce qu'il peut y avoir
de plus dangereux dans une société
éclatée au fond
la française on aime bien des normes qui
s'appliquerait à tous comme ça touche à
la question des libertés effectivement
il peut y avoir un risque de montrer du
doigt des personnes qui pour des raisons
fort diverses sont opposés à la
vaccination
ce que je trouve un peu dangereux c'est
un système de nasse où le politique sans
doute par insuffisante des gîtes inité
ou par un provisionnement de vaccins
insuffisant dans l'immédiat au fond ne
dit pas il faut vacciner tout le monde
mais prendre des mesures qui vont amener
un phénomène de boulot qui est en fait
une pression que je trouve funeste dans
la mesure où effectivement on le voit
l'intérieur des familles politiques
l intérieur même des faits il y tout
court ce débat est un débat assez
violent ce qui est une façon de rappeler
qu'une société ne tient pas
essentiellement sur des questions
économiques et sociales
le saurait elle tient d'abord si on se
met en société c'est que d'abord nous se
pose la question comment bien affronter
ensemble notre destin et comme la france
depuis des siècles fonctionne aux
politiques
cette question est devenue éminemment
explosive et effectivement il ya là un
risque de ferments de divisions alors à
la vas voir ce que disent ceux ci celle
des tirs instance va voir si les projets
bon réellement passé mais c'est
effectivement une privation de liberté
individuelle pour des raisons sanitaires
alors je suis d'accord avec notre avec
monsieur chiche
hors de question de parler du terme de
dictature mais au fond un peu comme le
vaccin
on pourrait se dire que cette idée de
passe c'est une bonne idée
sur le court terme en termes sanitaires
mais on aura de longs de moyen et de
long terme c'est à dire que on sent
qu'on est avec le pass sanitaire engagé
dans un processus nouveau gain de nature
quantique dont on ne maîtrise pas
ensuite ce que pourraient être les
effets sous avec d'autres gouvernements
soient appliquées à d'autres domaines
alors vous évoquez stéphanoise effarant
destin commun rené schickelé non
vaccinés représente aujourd'hui à
quelques 80 % des cas positifs comment
préserver les libertés de tous sont
touchés aux libertés individuelles
on vous avait montré n'est sur le
terrain je ne veux pas aller c'était
celui de la vaccination se veut pas y
aller parce que on a roulé plus le droit
de s'exprimer là dessus
sauf à faire état de ses titres en
victime en épidémiologie mais pourtant
un certain nombre de choses que l'on
entends bhl est ce la raison la
vaccination s'est d'abord fait pour se
protéger ce point d'accord donc si un
vaccin est efficace et si vous continuez
on ne comprend pas pourquoi il faut
l'imposer à tous le monde étant donné
que les personnes qui sont venues plus
intéressé par la vaccination sont celles
qui présentent des risques et qu'on
appelle dans les textes réglementaires
des personnes vulnérables
effectivement sur des domaines
comparables je veux dire comparable en
terme de rapport entre les traitements
et la gravité de la magouille on ne peut
pas mettre au plus les 25 sur l'année
toutes les vaccinations s'il ya des
vaccinations obligatoires des maladies
extrêmement grave qui qui qui qui sont
constamment être traités mais ce qui
l'est plus dans le plus comparable aux
vocaux vide en fait c'est la grippe je
dis pas que le public y est évidemment
des choses très différentes mais du
point de vue de la vaccination c'est
comparable
or en réalité les personnes vaccinées
sont aussi contagieux pas tout à fait
autant contagieuse que celles qui ne
sont pas vaccinés mais elles sont
néanmoins contagieuse et par conséquent
quand on analyse de près l'avant projet
de loi on se rend compte que d'un simple
point de vue logique c'est totalement
aberrant de réserver l'accès de lieux de
certains lieux de la vie quotidienne à
des personnes qui peuvent présenter un
certificat de vaccination alors qu'en
réalité elles sont contagieuses même si
et le président maintenant at il lui
même dans son discours la ddt de la ji
même si c'est deux fois moins que des
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés
là il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas on
est en train d'utiliser la vaccination
comme instrument pour que diminuer la
circulation du virus alors que la
vaccination elle est à l'origine
et je dirais presque par définition fait
pour se prémunir contre des
complications et contre le développement
de la maladie
ce sont deux choses complètement
différentes donc on est en train une
fois de plus d'utiliser un instrument à
d'autres fins que celles pour lesquelles
il est
il établit un logis voilà ça c'est très
important parce que si on comprend pas
bien ça alors effectivement tout le
reste tout le reste on accepte mais je
voudrais quand même revenir sur ce qu'a
dit mon interlocuteur tout à l'heure
rozès à savoir que quand même il faut
quand même pas oublier qu'il y a très
peu de temps nous nous dirigeons
ministre on ne rien dire du président
lui même avait exclu avec les mesures
qui sont en train de prendre
alors il ya effectivement un autre dégât
collatéral de cette mesure à 106 kg et
la perte totale de crédit de la parole
politique et ça ça va c'est ans à long
terme
terrifiante stéphane rozès et ce sera le
dernier mot avec vous parce que
malheureusement le temps nous manque et
voter sur cette question du traitement
différencié entre vacciner et non
vaccinés est ce que vous considérez que
rendre la vaccination obligatoire pour
l'enfant que des françaises comme la
mesure où elles étaient mieux accueillis
selon vous je suis ce qui me trouble si
c'est la question que vous passez
sanitaires plus que la question de la
vaccination mais le départ serait
effectivement entre eux
engagement personnel et dimension
collective des questions sanitaires ça
n'est pas si compliqué qui mériterait
une victime en deux temps avec monsieur
chiche sur la question discrédit de la
parole politique n'est pas au fait n'est
pas un désaccord ce que je reproche
ouvert une âme au fond ce n'est pas que
la situation change et que le politique
doivent s'adapter la situation car c'est
l'euro même du politique la différence
entre le scientifique et le politique
c'est que le politique doit lui a remis
près des dimensions fort différente hoc
la situation peut changer mais c'est
vrai que depuis le départ a soutenu l as
des as depuis lundi
mais oui mais oui mais deçà ça au fond
non non mais par contre au départ
effectivement il ya un problème des
français au départ il ya discrète au
départ nos concitoyens ne crois pas y
compris sur matière sanitaire pas la
parole publique parce que sur tout un
tas de dossiers sur l'efficacité même
d'un certain nombre de mesures le
politique et même des autorités
médicales ne disait pas le réel mais
notre possible ce qui est très différent
donc effectivement dès le départ il y a
eu un problème et je pense que
d'ailleurs ce discrédit politique fait
que le politique peut être amené à tort
à mon avis à finasser sur un certain
nombre de principes et où concis ça d'un
point de vue politologique est
inquiétant parce que plus les temps sont
troublés plus une attente du politique
au fond il rassemble et non pas qu'ils
sont facturés et ce sont donc 114 mille
protestataires qui sont descendus
aujourd'hui dans les rues un peu partout
en france pour dénoncer l'extension du
pain sanitaire merci à tous les deux
mais c'est d'avoir participé à cet
échange ce soir stéphane rozès
politologue et président de cap conseils
analyses et perspectives et rené fischer
historien professeur de philosophie